well christian we're gearing up for tax
filing season it begins this friday
thousands of unemployment claimants
receive their special forms and many
have questions about filing
even fraud concerns joe moeller joins us
live outside deter headquarters with the
answers joe
well curious a lot of people who are
getting a head start on their taxes are
saying these numbers just
aren't adding up well according to some
sources this is because the numbers
don't reflect all the money you receive
now some are saying their portals totals
are different than the 1099g form what
isn't necessarily listed
is the extra weekly payments and other
benefits received over the year now
sierra neal runs a popular facebook
group she says she already filed her
taxes
out online to be submitted on friday she
says the
extra payment should pop up after
inputting the information into the tax
filing system
so you're not going to see a lot of
those extra payments but you will see
what you're getting
out what your weekly benefit amount is
basically
and then it will also eventually it
should
be popping up within the system those
the extra money the 600s the 300.
now another big issue is tax fraud
dieter recognizes there is a major fraud
issue when it comes to these
1099 tax forms now if you believe you
received an incorrect
1099g you can file report with the
agency by visiting the deter website and
selecting the unemployment fraud tab
on the left under quick links and then
clicking on the 1099g
correction request now a professional
tax
person should be sought after if you do
have a lot of questions but
also a good idea as well when you do
file these is to keep your records for
the future just in case reporting live
here at dieter joe mohler 8 news now